[Musique]
à 25 ans Sébastien a trouvé sa voie le
travail du bois de goyavier cela fait
maintenant 2 ans qu'il a intégré
l'atelier de bois goyavier du
département avec en poche un B de
menuiserie un bac pro de menuiserie
d'agencement
m le métier
PL le BO c'est c'est une c'est une not
étape de laerie
comme faut savoir et le c'est la
baseia
bouarin c'est Leme et après le textile
la
pierre le ver tout ça fait
M ça
c'est un trésor la
Réunion une autre manière de travailler
le bois très différent de son
apprentissage mais qui plaît à Sébastien
tout comme lui ben après son beep
menuiserie avait du mal à trouver du
travail et puis une réunion à la Mission
Locale l'informe qu'un atelier de boî
goyavier est en train de se développer
j'étais un peu curieux je suis venu
parce que voilà comme il m'a dit c'est
un peu c'est un peu comme de l'art ben
j'ai continué j'ai continué à à aller
dans les réunions après ben on est
rentrer
et petit à petit c'était pas facile au
début mais après quand quand tu aimes
vraiment le truc ben ça marche très bien
après ben j'ai commencé à avoir beaucoup
de responsabilités j'ai commencé à aimer
à aimer jusqu'à là là ça va faire 1 an
peut-être 2 ans si ça se marche bien
Sébastien et Ben sont désormais des
ouvriers qualifiés qui travaillent sous
les directive de Jean-François Warot à
l'origine du projet de développement de
la filière de boî de goyavier une
impulsion du département a permis de
développer toute une gamme de produits
issu de cette peste végétale et la
dernière création date montre les
perspectives innombrables que cache ce
matériaux qui désormais a obtenu ses
lettres de noblesse nous sommes ici à la
saladine les Bains en village coraille
un ensemble de logements insolit qui a
été construit il y a pas que du bois de
goyavier il y a surtout en terme de
superstructure le squelette des des des
cabanes c'est du rondin en cryptomeria
euh après oui il y a du
goyevier il y a aussi de laacassia une
autre pisse envahissante cabane dans les
arbres ou encore cabane forestière tous
les savoir-faire se sont unis pour
permettre de sortir de sable ce
prototype parmi les métiers celui de
tapissier Rachad ne pensait pas un jour
travailler le tissu ici ce sont des
rideaux des têtes de lit les bancs qui
ont été habillés tapissier ben il fait
tout ce qu' dit les BES assis tout ce
qui dit déco quoi déco en en général
quoi vois et à la base c'est quelque
chose que est qu'on nous regarde ben
c'est lui qui frappe en premier sur les
yeux la décoration après les gens
regardent plutôt dans le détail mais en
premier c'est décoration ben nous nousvi
en premier donc il veut dire que les
complémentaires ben à nous nous apporte
aussi un quelque chose comment dire ça
euh d'assez délicat on retrouve rachade
en plein travail à l'atelier boî
goyavier au choudron avec son formateur
Mathieu je sors d'une école l'école des
compagnons qui prône la transmission du
métier du savoir-faire il a vu mon
atelier il venait souvent me voir
s'intéressait au métier donc du coup
c'est vrai que on lui a proposé de venir
travailler avec moi pour déjà mes po et
c'est vrai qu'il est très intéressé pose
beaucoup de questions donc ça c'est très
important et il s'intéresse et c'est
vrai que bah moi je je suis satisfait de
de Rachad parce que voilà il a il a du
potentiel et je pense qu'il pourra faut
qu'ilue là-dedans un parcours exemplaire
pour ces trois jeunes qui désormais ont
des projets plein la tête permettre la
transmission mais surtout mesurer la
motivation élément essentielle à une
réussite professionnelle le parcours de
recrutement ne se fait pas au hasard on
reçoit les les jeunes en entretien pour
le expliquer un petit peu euh le le
processus dans lequel ils vont entrer en
intégrant la filière boî goyavier
ensuite on a après l'entretien on a une
étape on va dire d'immersion et de
découverte de la filler boî guillavier
et de l'atelier de recherche et d'ESS
autour des matériaux naturels euh se
poursuit ensuite une phase de de
d'approfondissement de ces connaissances
et compétences acquéries durant la phase
de découverte et ensuite nous continuons
sur une étape qu'on appelle étable de
spécialisation où là nous invitons le
jeune à approfondir son projet
professionnel
personnel en travaillant davantage sur
des spécialités autour des matériaux
naturels et du boî goyavier notamment
des technique qui souhaite vraiment
approfondir surtout ça la mission du
boîgavier hormi mettre une filière en
place tout le travail intermédiaire
c'était
comment transmettre de la compétence
et acquérir pour ces jeunes de la
compétence pour atterrir sur le secteur
marchand la filière boî goyavier a
permis à des jeunes de se former à des
artistes de Cré des objets qui ornent
désormais nos espaces publics mais
également nos maison une finition
magnifique qui donne naissance à des
intérieurs dignes des plus grands hôtels
comme ici l'espace jacuzzi le bois de
goyavier all à d'autres matériaux ouvre
des perspectives économiques avec à la
clé des emplois made in
runion
[Musique]